Ласкаво просимо до Парми штат Огайо тихе
містечко з населенням 80 тисяч стало
центром боротьби за підтримку України
сполученими штатами майже половина
населення має українське походження
традиційно вони підтримували
республіканців але цього року Все може
змінитися ця пекарня знаходиться в
самому серці Парми і відомо своїми
українським стравами наші вареники добре
відомі в усьому світі тому що ми маємо
деякі додаткові смаки разом із
традиційними
мати Лідії сама біженка з України стала
власницею пекарні ще в 1974 році
коли ми почули про війну тієї ночі коли
стався перший напад ми всю ніч не спали
тому що в мене в Україні є двоюрідні
брати і сестри тож одразу ж наступною
суботи ми пожертвували на потреби
України всі кошти від продажу вареників
тоді зібрали близько 10 тисяч доларів це
війна не просто тисячі миль звідси вона
прямо тут вона на нашому порозі вона у
наших телефонах вона в наших електронних
листах вона відбувається з нами і це те
саме що сталося з нашими батьками які
переїхали сюди
напередодні виборів ця підтримка стала
дуже політизованою в штаті огаю Джеймса
Девід венс кандидат у сенат від
республіканської партії і ось яка його
позиція
підхід Америка немає ігнорувати проблеми
власної країни зосереджуючись натомість
на Україні давайте зосередимося на
власних проблемах наших громадян і
будемо ігнорувати кандидатів які хочуть
щоб ми вели війну з Володимиром Путіним
тому що це зможе їх відчувати себе
крутими це звучить дуже занепокійливе
для людей які переживають за ситуацією в
Україні а їхні голоси важливі бо
результати вагаю не передбачувані і
голосування етнічних українців може
стати вирішальним
Я думаю що це ганьба Що це стало
питанням яке популяризується у США коли
розпочалася війна була підтримка обох
партій
я постійно голосував за консерваторів
але я не буду голосувати за цього
Джеймса Девіда венсон тому що він не
представляє консервативну філософію до
якої Я належу
досвідчений республіканський стеблішмент
Огайо та США розуміє важливість України
та підтримує Україну але про трампійські
республіканці схожі що ні
наші діти дивляться що саме ми залишимо
для наступного покоління це про них це
про дітей які не мають тому
для багатьох тут у армій підтримка
України - це не політика це питання
життя чи смерті і це може змусити
багатьом американців українського
походження проголосувати не за
республіканців а за демократів
нагадаємо проміжні вибори мі-тьомс
проходять у США всередині чотирирічного
президентського терміну і якщо зазвичай
змій приділяють їм набагато менше уваги
ніж президентським то цього разу їхні
результати можуть істотно вплинути на
розстановку силу Вашингтоні та
відповідно на світову політику під час
проміжних виборів перебирається вся
Палата представників тобто 435 місць у
Нижній палаті Конгресу США а також трохи
більше третини місць зі ста у сенаті за
традицією проміжні вибори є чимось на
кшталт лакмусового папірця щодо
підтримки виборцями чинного президента
та його партії
як правило на проміжних виборах партія
президента не досягає добрих результатів
і одна з головних речей які можна
побачити - це рівень схвалення
президента та стану справ в економіці
за тиждень до виборів багато аналітиків
прогнозують що американські виборці
невдоволені насамперед економічною
ситуацією зокрема зростанням цін та
інфляції в Україні забезпечить
республіканцям справжній переможний вал
водночас деякі спостерігачів оцінюють
ситуацію з точністю до навпаки демократи
неприречені результат виборів далеко не
вирішений більшість висновків про те як
пройдуть проміжні вибори неправильні і
засновані на нерозумінні даних про
вибори так уже історично склалося що
партія яка контролює Білий дім зазвичай
програє на проміжних виборах але це
відбувається не через те що насправді
думають люди справжня причина полягає в
тому що виборці правлячі партії
заспокоюються і не приходять на вибо в
тій самій кількості щойно президентські
Тому зараз все залежатиме від явки
скільки з цих виборців знову пройдуть на
вибори саме це і визначить чи переможуть
демократи чи втримують вони палату
представників і чи збільшать свою
перевагу в сеті
обидві партії проводять компанії на
ключові теми які хвилюють і їхніх
виборців
зараз є 5 можливо 6 сенатських перегонів
де з опитуваннями обидва кандидати
перебувають у межах арифметичної похибки
один від одного це Аризона Невада
Джорджія вісконсен Пенсільванія та
можливо Північна Кароліна і те які теми
нинішніх виборів є найважливішими і
багато в чому залежить від того З ким ви
розмовляєте для багатьох республіканців
незалежних кандидатів та демократів це
інфляція та економіка електорат
республіканців схильні більше цікавитися
питаннями і організації та безпеки
демократи вважають обмеження прав на
аборти однієї з головних тем яка хвилює
і їхніх прихильників
боротьба за темношкірих виборців
переважно більшість яких завжди
голосувала за демократів цього разу
обіцяє бути особливо жорсткою адже
згідно запитуваннями багато хто з них
розчарований політикою нинішньої
адміністрації щоправда на користь
демократів вказує той факт що їхні
прихильники частіше голосують дострокову
поштою і явка на нинішніх виборах
зрештою у них може бути вищою ніж у
республіканців проте високі шанси
республіканців на перемогу трубуть Київ
і всіх у США хто підтримує Україну її
боротьбі проти російської агресії таких
згідно запитуваннями у США абсолютно
більшість водночас багато кандидатів від
республіканців напередодні виборів
висловлювалися за обмеження підтримки
Києва і навіть заповни її скасування
деякі з них виступають за невтручання у
проблеми Європи та світу і закликають
сконцентруватися на внутрішніх питаннях
що у травні конгресу хвалив закон про
масштабний пакет допомоги Україні на
загальну суму 40 мільярдів доларів за
проголосували всі демократи та більшість
республіканців у палаті представників
але 57 республіканців тоді висловилися
проти поки що більшість республіканців
які керують фракціями партії у конгресі
і особливо міч маккона луценаті активно
виступають за допомогою Україні як би
там не було політологів впевнені
більшість в обох партіях переконана у
необхідності як військової так і
фінансової підтримки України на думку
аналітиків зовнішньополітичний курс США
навряд чи зміниться після проміжних
виборів
не думаю що республіканська партія
отримає більшість у 60 голосів у сенаті
а тому виникне багато патових ситуацій
крім того на все ще є президент Байден
який ймовірно накладе вето на будь-які
законопроєкти які висунули
республіканська партія які можуть сильно
змінити політичний курс тож Мені
здається ми Швидше рухаємося до ще
більшого застою в конгресі
на виборчій дільниці американці
вирушають у вівторок 8 листопада а
конгрес США у новому складі має
розпочати роботу вже першого січня